[Musica]
nella mia vita ho sempre avuto poche
certezze però di una cosa sono sempre
stata sicura e cioè che c'erano i maschi
e che c'erano le femmine
poi sono cresciuto e sono diventata
mamma e ho avuto tre figli
la grande è una femmina 13 anni il
piccolo e un maschio e 7 anni e quello
di mezzo come dice lui è un po tutte e
due un maschio e una femmina è a 9 anni
mio figlio infatti fin da quando era
piccolino ha sempre mostrato una
predilezione per tutto quello che
apparteneva al mondo femminile dai
vestiti ai giochi al modo proprio di
giocare alle immedesimarsi soltanto in
tutti quelli che erano i personaggi
femminili dei cartoni animati o anche
dei debiti games è così e io onestamente
non ci ho mai trovato niente di male
mia figlia aveva sempre giocato con il
lego dei pompieri è permesso li voleva
giocare con le principesse disney non
c'era assolutamente nessun problema
finché intorno ai 3 anni ha incominciato
a chiedervi mamma ma quand'è che posso
diventare una bambina e lì ho capito che
effettivamente poteva esserci qualcosa
che non era esattamente lo stesso che
aveva riguardato mia figlia e ho
cominciato a farmi delle domande anche
se l'ho sempre lasciato libero di essere
quello che lui sentiva di essere ho
cominciato a informarmi però non ho mai
trovato assolutamente niente che
riguardasse l'argomento finché un giorno
sospinta dagli amici che mi dicevano che
sbagliavo ad assecondarlo che dovevo
cominciare a comprargli le macchinine ai
robot i fucili sono andato da una
psicologa dell'infanzia e mi sono
informata per sapere da lei se facevo
bene o facevo male questa psicologa mi
ha detto che non mi ha assolutamente
parlato di identità di genere e mi ha
soltanto parlato mi ha detto forse tuo
figlio da grande sarà omosessuale per
cui io sono tornato a casa ho detto va
bene pace per me non era un problema e
ho continuato a lasciarlo libero di
essere però contemporaneamente mi sono
messa a parlare con i miei amici
omosessuali chiedendo loro come era come
era stata la loro infanzia se per vedere
se trovavo degli argomenti che potevano
essere condivisi con la vita di mio
figlio
e loro mi dicevano che loro non avevano
mai sentito l'esigenza di essere femmina
non avevano mai voluto vestirsi da
femmina o giocare con le cose la femmina
per cui mi dicevano mi spingevano a
indagare oltre e io mi trovavo mai
niente finché a un certo punto mi sono
ho avuto l'illuminazione siccome io
parlo molto bene inglese di metterne a
cercare in inglese e nei momenti in cui
mi sono messo a cercare in inglese mi
sono resa conto che fuori dall italia
esisteva un mondo infinito di bambini
come il mio e di famiglie come la mia in
cui i bambini non si riconoscevano nel
loro sesso biologico
cercando su internet soprattutto nei
paesi anglosassoni stati uniti
inghilterra e australia
ho visto che il quello che poteva essere
definito diciamo il problema anche se di
problema non si trattava di mio figlio
era che esistono moltissimi bambini che
nascono biologicamente di un sesso ma
non si riconoscono nel loro sesso
biologico perché realtà esiste un sesso
biologico è un sesso psichico e io devo
dire la verità quando ho scoperto questa
cosa non mi sono sentita angosciata mi
sono sentita sollevata perché trovando
una una motivazione
sapevo anche un po come muovermi come
come agire e facevo spesso l'errore fino
a qualche anno fa di andare da mio
figlio e chiedergli ma tu ti senti
maschi o ti senti femmina e lui ogni
volta mi guardava molto stupito ci
pensavo un attimo e poi mi diceva boh io
mi sento io e io lì per lì questa
risposto a nulla capivo e poi dopo un po
di tempo ho capito che in realtà lui
aveva ragione ci siamo noi cresciuti in
un pensiero binario in cui l'uomo è un
maschio o femmina che tendiamo a
catalogare le persone fin da quando sono
piccoli e incastrare in uno stereotipo
di genere che deve appartenere per forza
o al maschile o al femminile in realtà
un bambino è una creatura vergine da
tutti i punti di vista e se non è
influenzato dall esterno è semplicemente
chi è e se osserviamo la società che ci
circonda questa binarie ta sta
diventando sempre più estremi
in tutti in tutto quanto appunto dagli
ovini kinder che ormai sono da maschio
da femmina una volta c'erano meno kinder
era uno fine la penna bic era uno adesso
anche la penna bic c'è da maschio e c'è
da femmina i vestiti fin dai bambini
piccolissimi sono da super sembrano
delle mini delle mini donne queste
bambine e i maschi dei superuomini fin
da piccolini per cui dei bambini che si
sentono non perfettamente rappresentati
dallo stereotipo di genere di adesso
cominciano poi un certo punto a sentire
l'influenza del mondo esterno che gli
deve per forza indirizzare da una parte
o da quell'altra e anche i genitori
tendiamo a fare l'errore di mandarli o
di qua o di là anche perché
effettivamente più semplice perché nei
momenti in cui rimane così nel mezzo e
le persone non sanno darti un etichetta
le persone vanno in crisi
mi ricordo l'anno scorso vietare con mio
figlio c'era stato un periodo difficile
a scuola c'erano dei bambini che lo
prendevano in giro e quindi la maestra
era andato un po in crisi non sapeva più
come gestire la situazione e siamo
andati insieme dalla dalla psicologa che
per un periodo che aveva fatto una
valutazione a mio figlio per capire fino
a quando lui poteva a quanto potesse
sentire il disagio di questo suo modo di
essere diverso diciamo dal dal normale e
mi ricordo che dopo aver parlato con la
psicologa la psicologa mi ha detto
guarda via tuo figlio che se si sente a
disagio che non sa come gestire la
situazione sia bisogno di parlare con me
io sono qui a disposizione proprio
quando sono a casa che l'ho detto e lui
mi ha guardato e mi ha detto mamma e non
deve andarci ore la psicologa
io non ho nessun problema a vestirmi
come mi vesto può essere chi sono sono
gli altri che ci devono andare per
capire perché loro fanno fatica a
gestire un bambino che c'è una maglietta
rosa effettivamente devo dire che questo
argomento mette in discussione tutto il
nostro modo di vedere di vedere la
realtà
se uno riesce ad andare oltre e capire
questi bambini che cosa riescono a
insegnarti
il fatto è che spesso i bambini che non
vengono accettati che effettivamente
non si riconoscono nel loro sesso
biologico e vengono costretti a vivere
nello stereotipo che la società si
aspetta da loro crescendo arrivano poi a
un certo punto prima della pubertà che
non possono più giocare sulla cosa
perché con la pubertà
a quel punto o sei maschio o sei femmina
se questi bambini non sono stati accolti
e anno non hanno sviluppato un carattere
abbastanza forte
vanno totalmente in crisi si è visto io
l'ho io sono io parlo sempre da mamma
per cui non do termini scientifici però
i dati su l'unico dato scientifico che
per me è essenziale dire è che questi
ragazzini quando arrivano alla pubertà
quelli che non sono stati accolti della
famiglia il 41 per cento tenta il
suicidio e spesso ci riesce
io pensavo che fosse un dato così un po
da dato per spaventare invece realtà poi
confrontandomi con altre famiglie
ho avuto la risposta che effettivamente
era così questi bambini spesso diventano
anoressici perché sanno che se non
mangiano si blocca lo sviluppo e allora
il corpo non si sviluppa oppure
diventano bulimici perché ingrassando il
seno si nasconde diciamo nel sovrappeso
tutta una serie di cose che sono
veramente tremende per cui questi
bambini vanno assolutamente accolti fin
da piccoli
tutto questo di cui ho parlato fino
adesso ha un nome e il nome disforia di
genere la disforia di genere è una mal
sopportazione e il genere ovviamente
genere biologico la disforia di genere
purtroppo è ancora inserito all'interno
del manuale diagnostico e statistico
delle malattie psichiatriche a me
onestamente quando mi hanno detto questo
e pensavo a mio figlio mi è preso un
colpo anche perché onestamente mio
figlio un bambino simpatico intelligente
come tutti gli altri gioca birbone come
tutti non ha nessuna caratteristica di
un bambino che posso avere una malattia
psichiatrica
in realtà il problema è che è la società
che non accettando t a un certo punto ti
crea tutta una serie di
effettivamente di disforia di mal
sopportazione però non non è una cosa
innata di questi quindi questi ragazzini
si se arriva un certo punto che faticano
ad accettare il loro corpo però quanti
bambini adolescenti faticano ad
accettare il loro corpo se intorno hanno
avuto una famiglia accogliente degli
amici accoglienti e la scuola
accogliente ci arrivano più o meno come
tutti gli altri
il mio problema era stato che per
scoprire tutte queste cose però sempre
dovuta rivolgere all'estero per cui
parlare con le associazioni all'estero
con le famiglie vedevo una conferenza le
conferenze ted degli stati uniti mi
hanno sempre aiutato tantissimo perché
spesso parlavano delle mamme che
raccontano le storie identiche alla mia
è però in italia non non c'era mai
assolutamente niente e chiedevo se
qualcuno conosceva dei bambini come il
mio nessuno conosceva dei bambini come
il mio finché a un certo punto ho deciso
di aprire un blog che è il mio blog che
si chiama mio figlio in rosa e che
racconta appunto la nostra storia che
non è stato scritto per esibizionismo è
stato scritto perché anche sotto parere
della della psicologa a cui io spesso mi
rivolgo per consigli su come comportarmi
ho pensato che se mi esponevo io
raccontando normalmente la mia storia
senza nessun tipo di vergogna perché non
c'è niente di cui vergognarsi anzi è
probabilmente delle famiglie che erano
nella mia stessa situazione avrebbero
contattato me esattamente come io avevo
contattato le famiglie all'estero e
quindi a fine agosto ho aperto questo
blog ho parlato con i miei figli che
cosa ne pensavano loro erano
d'accordissimo anzi mio figlio era
strafelice perché così ha detto che non
che le persone avrebbero cominciato a
sapere come era la sua storia e quindi
forse si sarebbero trovati anche degli
altri bambini che condividevano le sue
stesse passioni effettivamente appena
uscito il blog piano piano hanno
cominciato a contattarmi a contattarmi
delle famiglie e adesso siamo un po da
tutta italia
mi hanno contattato anche dall'estero
famiglie italiane che abitano in nuova
zelanda a new york in inghilterra che
hanno il problema che lì vivono serene
ma quando poi vengono in italia hanno i
nonni gli zii e cugini che vanno in
crisi perché non capiscono che cos'è
questa storia e quindi piano piano
parlandone perché fondamentalmente il
problema che c'è è che non c'è
informazione per cui bisogna parlarne
non bisogna vergognarsi non c'è niente
di problemi insomma le cose di cui
vergognarsi nella vita sono altre questi
bambini sono bambini come tutti gli
altri forse gli va dato un occhio di
riguardo in più perché effettivamente
possono avere più difficoltà a
integrarsi
però a parte quello non non c'è non c'è
niente che non vada quindi oggi ha 46
anni grazie ai miei figli ho capito che
non esiste solo maschio è solo femmina
ma esiste una varietà infinita di
possibilità e tutte vanno assolutamente
accettate ma soprattutto ho capito mio
figlio mi ha insegnato che nessuno va
giudicato e così la cosa che io dico
sempre a tutti è di raccontare la mia
storia di raccontare le storie simili
alla mia di non di non tenersi le cose
per sé ed a non giudicare quando ci
troviamo di fronte a un adulto che non
rappresentano la nostra idea di persona
al nostro stereotipo di maschio
il nostro stereotipo di femmina perché
quella adulto di oggi era il bambino che
oggi è mio figlio e che quindi ha
bisogno anche lui di tutta l'accoglienza
di tutta la comprensione di cui hanno
bisogno tutti quanti